bonjour la voie est libre en direct tous
les samedis sur france 3 avec
aujourd'hui une colère celle d'un
certain nombre de maires ruraux qui
s'inquiètent de la réforme en cours ce
qu'on appelle la loi notre
l'organisation des territoires cette
fonction mère va-t-elle disparaître
noyés dans les intercommunalités plus
largement quel est la place des
territoires ruraux dans la république
pour répondre à ces questions et pour en
débattre sur notre plateau dominique
vais rien meredith saint sauveur en
puisaye bonjour vous êtes présidente de
l'association des maires ruraux de
l'yonne patrick molinoz maire radical de
gauche de vénarey-les-laumes en
côte-d'or bonjour vous êtes aussi vice
président de l'association des maires de
france jean-françois farenc merdes
blanot président de l'association des
maires ruraux de saône-et-loire
bondrieux et fabien bazin maire
socialiste de l'orme dans la nièvre vous
êtes aussi conseiller départemental de
l'anr bonjour
et chez vous vous pouvez réagir comme
d'habitude sur les réseaux sociaux
twitter et sur notre site internet le
message du week-end dernier c'était donc
village sacrifier une opération
coordonnée par l'association des maires
ruraux pour protester contre la fameuse
loi nôtre qui est en discussion devant
le parlement hier soir encore au sénat
d'ailleurs déjà voté en première lecture
à l'assemblée notre pour on va essayer
de faire simple nouvelle organisation
territoriale de la république une loi
très important qui va fixer des limites
et les compétences de toutes les
collectivités et quand je lis les traque
de la mr2 week-end dernier vous avez la
main lourde je vous cite sur certains
tracts l'heure est grave les libertés
des citoyens sont menacés alors moi je
pensais qu'il s'agissait de savoir qui
des communes ou des communautés de
communes allait s'occuper de l'eau ou
des écoles dominique vais rien en quoi
est-ce que l'heure est grave
alors l'heure est grave parce que
transférer techniquement un beaucoup de
compétences à une intercommunalité à
laquelle
enfin pour laquelle on décide qu'elle
devra avoir une taille précise est
relativement importante et ensuite faire
un amendement en parallèle qui permet
d'élire au suffrage universel direct
les instances qui la dirigeront frais
fera que cette intercommunale cette
intercommunalité excusez-moi aura un
pouvoir sur la commune
et le maire qui lui a été égal élu
j'ai un peu mal à m'excuser mois donc
l'intercommunalité aura ce pouvoir la
personne qui aurait été élu au suffrage
universel direct n'aura pas de lien avec
la mairie puisque ne sera plus issus de
la mairie comme elle l'est aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui l'intercommunalité c'est une
communauté de communes nous nous
associons les maires
s'associent ensemble demain s'il y a
deux élections à la fois la commune est
à la fois l'intercommunalité nous allons
avoir de pouvoirs sur une même sur un
même territoire dont un qui aura un
pouvoir supérieur à l'autre
si on suit la logique d'où la gravité de
la situation pour vous jean françois
parent qui vous étaient aussi dans cette
manifestation à arceaux en côte-d'or
bureau avec des allées des autres
départements de bourgogne moi ce que je
dirais c'est que là quand on regarde ce
texte de loi qui est très long qui fait
200 pages je trouve que la commune est
oublié d'ailleurs c'est significatif si
vous regardez les titres cette loi des
grands titres des régions renforcée par
titre un titre deux des
intercommunalités renforcée et puis il
ya quelques autres titres plus technique
mais rien sur la commune c'est à dire
que auprès lève on enlève des
compétences aux communes comme on l'a
déjà fait là il ya une nouvelle série de
compétences qui sont transférées aux
intercommunalités et on ne dit pas ce
qui doit rester à la commune ou non on
ne pense pas ce que doit être la commune
et notamment la commune rurale dans les
années qui viennent qu'est-ce qu'elle
qu'est ce qui doit relever vraiment de
sa compétence et qui doit rester donc en
proximité
sur les responsabilités communales ça
l'ait pas dit c'est une loi qui s'occupe
des autres niveaux qui organise des
transferts de responsabilité vers
d'autres niveaux et qui ne parle pas de
la commune patrick molinoz est ce que
vous faites la même interprétation vous
de ce qui est en train de se décider où
il vous semble que ce qui est en train
de se faire et plutôt positive je fais
une interprétation
assez semblable avec ce bémol c'est que
l'objectif de la réforme est lui
totalement loi c'est à dire qu'on peut
pas rester systématiquement en
permanence dans des fonctionnements un
peu ancestraux qui trouvent leurs
limites
le monde a évolué la place des communes
est à mon sens essentiel et on doit
garder les communes à partir du moment
où il ya une volonté d'organisation sur
les territoires on doit garder les
communes et les communes rurales et les
petites communes ont toute leur raison
d'être sauf que la réalité de l'exercice
des actions les communes quand on est
dans une commune de 50 habitants d'une
commune de 5000 c'est déjà pas la même
et dans une de 5000 d une de 30000 c'est
pas la même donc l'objectif de dire il
faut qu'on trouve les moyens de
revitaliser le rural il est bon sauf que
les moyens qui sont proposés
effectivement sont extrêmement
inquiétant et j'espère qu'on y reviendra
il ya autre chose qui rend la situation
extrêmement difficile pour les mères en
ce moment et à ce projet de loi qui est
encore en discussion qui sort du sénat
il y aura une commission mixte paritaire
et y aura un vote de l'assemblée fin
juillet mais il ya une autre situation
qui est l immédiate et bugle et
l'urgence total c'est celle des
dotations et un sou mais oui mais oui 2
mai vous parler d'argent pour ça je dois
dire que la mrc un message par la loi
noterez la mf l'organisation des maires
de france et françois baroin a plus
beaucoup sur les finances on apprend on
appuie sur les finances en ce moment
parce que c'est le sujet de la
préparation de la loi de finances 2016
et sont les discussions avec le
gouvernement actuellement et ça c'est de
l'immédiateté cd effet tout de suite la
réforme de la loi notre elle aura des
effets positifs ou négatifs dans le
temps il ya des choses inadmissibles
dans la loi notre moi je suis pas contre
l'intercommunalité on doit raisonner
bloc vous êtes comme le président d'une
autre énorme l'intercommunalité elle a
un rôle elle permet de faire sur une
échelle ce que les plus petites communes
ne faisait en réalité pas hier on ne
pouvait plus faire donc
l'intercommunalité n'est pas en cause et
là une véritable utilité simplement
le gouvernement sur cette loi sur
certains sujets se plante à mon sens
complètement notamment sur celui des
seuils de population sarkozy l'avait
déjà fait en mettant un seuil des 1 5000
contre lequel nous étions élevé à
l'époque quand même et moins que
j'essaie d'être cohérent dans le temps
je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne trouverai
inacceptable 5000 habitants partout en
france de la même manière il ya cinq ans
ou six ans et je trouverais acceptable
20000 aujourd'hui bazin oui enfin moi je
pense qu'on est là sur la question des
deux de l'outillage la façon dont tout
ça va être va être mené bon c'est très
bien on peut faire effectivement 40
minutes de discussion là dessus non on
va pas faire terminer je pense que ce
serait mieux en effet le sujet je crois
que c'est important de le rappeler dès
maintenant quand même un mot sur les
abeilles sur cette idée de communes et
intercommunalités parce que d'abord
c'est un bien beau les journées france
elle découvre un peu finalement parce
que pour les français ils ont le maire
il ya un département il ya une région
intercomités n'existe pas vraiment et on
a l'impression que ça a du mal à passer
finalement dans les mentalités mais bien
sûr mais attendez l'intercommunalité
c'est un outil qui est au service des
communes voilà c'est à ça que ça sert ça
permet de délivrer un certain nombre de
services exemple il ya vingt ans sur le
canton gloire de l'ancien canton de
lormes 4 10 communes moins de 4000
habitants quatre services de ramassage
des ordures ménagères quatre camions 4 x
3 gabon aujourd'hui intercommunalités un
seul service et on avance de manière
intelligente non il n'y a pas de
discussion enfin je crois pas entre nous
sur la question de l'intérêt de
l'intercommunalité et sur la question du
maintien des communes sont deux choses
différentes mais encore une fois
intercommunalités au service des
communes quand on est dans le monde
rural quand même ça aussi qui nous qui
est notre préoccupation si on ne dit pas
dès le début qu'on passe de un siècle et
demi d'exode rural d'un logiciel qui est
complètement intégrée par les uns et par
les autres on s'en bat la campagne a
plus rien c'est foutu les jeunes ils
n'ont pas de travail on trouve à la
ville après que le taux de chômage qu'on
a je suis pas certain qu'ils en trouvent
qu'ils en trouvent beaucoup plus on est
passé aujourd'hui à l'exode urbain vous
avez aujourd'hui 200 milles citadins
200000 cette année qui quittent les
métropoles pour revenir à la campagne
les désirs de deux campagnes sont
mesurés à fait ça très régulièrement ses
dix millions dix millions de citadins
qui ont un projet de vie à la campagne
dans 30 ans pas loin à 30 ans à
l'échelle de la vie d'une commune dans
trente ans on aura dix millions de
français en plus ou est-ce que vous
allez mettre on va pas continuer à
construire des maisons sur les ponts à
paris ces gens là ils vont revenir dans
les territoires donc tout l'enjeu de la
loi notre tout l'enjeu de nos
discussions c'est quelle organisation
locale on propose pour à la fois mieux
accueillir ceux qui sont en train
d'arriver le mouvement est déclenché
depuis plusieurs années et comment on
accompagne ceux qui ont tenu la baraque
pendant 50 ans un siècle est ainsi
qu'annie je pense que le débat est là
dessus pas forcément sur l'outil mais
sur commande aujourd'hui ont défini
ensemble une politique publique de la
ruralité efficace et respectueuse de
chacun on va y venir
dominer rien est ce qu'on doit
comprendre que la position des maires
ruraux cette souhaité que les
intercommunalités devienne pas un
échelon politique fort parce que est ce
que c'est ça qu'on doit comprendre en
transparent finalement et aux
intercommunalités qui seront forcément
grosse forcément élue avec un au
suffrage universel deviendront forcément
un élément politique dans le paysage et
moi j'ai envie de vous dire on a
commencé à le voir dans ces élections
départementales ou systématiquement dans
la constitution des binômes on voyait
apparaître systématiquement les
président qu'on appelle dans le jargon
les présidents des communes comme
systématiquement beaucoup plus qu'avant
est-ce que vous souhaitez justement que
ça n'arrive pas cros et les internautes
et devienne pas trop forte je pense
qu'il faut garder un petit peu de
cohérence on peut pas dire qu'on cherche
à retirer des feuilles au millefeuille
ajouté c'est parce qu'en fait on arrive
effectivement à rajouter une si jamais
on élit au suffrage universel direct ces
conseillers communautaires et pour le
coup la cause de menotter de communes ne
sera plus cet outil que nous appelons
effectivement tous de nos voeux au
service des communes ça deviendra une
instance dirigeante et politique puisque
le seuil de 20 mille va forcément
politisée et ça aussi on l'a vu au
moment des départementales on a bien vu
qu'avec ces grands cantons on a beaucoup
plus politisé les élections les
candidats n'étaient était beaucoup moins
connue sur le territoire sur l'ensemble
du grand territoire et quand on voit le
résultat que ça a pu donner dans l'yonne
je ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait envie de
vivre ça pour nos communautés de
communes en france à faire avec moi
j'avais envie de vous dire dans certains
de vos papiers au moment des
manifestations il y avait l'exemple de
des maires ruraux qui font des travaux
bénévolement dans leur commune on se
souvient qu'il ya beau si beaucoup aussi
de discussions sur la crise des
vocations pour les maires ruraux mais
paradoxalement si les maires ruraux au
moins à faire il y aura peut-être plus
de gens qui auront envie de le faire non
je pense pas je pense que la commune la
commune rurale est un échelon de presse
de proximité et si on a aujourd'hui
beaucoup de bénévolat beaucoup de gens
qui sont prêts à faire des travaux
bénévoles de l'entretien bénévoles des
comptes des conseillers municipaux qui
font des petites réparations c'est parce
que l'échelon et est proche et parce
qu'on s'engage plus facilement en
proximité que sur 1 sur un vaste
territoire la commune rurale d'ailleurs
pour faire le lien avec le la question
des finances publiques c'est quelque
chose de sobre la commune rurale et
qu'elle a été un échelon qui a été très
très sobre au plan ou plan budgétaire
parce qu'il ya une somme de bénévolat ça
ne sonne coûte rien aux finances
publiques et si vous additionnez tous le
bénévolat quotidien hebdomadaire qui est
fait je pense qu on a des sommes assez
assez conséquente qui sont fait parler
les les petites municipal gamme est
vraiment réagissait sur sur deux choses
l'histoire du millefeuille il faut aussi
qu'on arrête il ya autant de niveaux de
collectivités en allemagne en italie en
espagne qu'en france le sujet c'est pas
le millefeuille ça c'est un truc qu'on a
mis dans le débat public et les médias
ont beaucoup ont beaucoup relayé qu'il
n'est pas une réalité le sujet c'est
comment on collabore mieux avec les
partenaires et les partenaires ce n'est
pas que l'intercommunalité c'est encore
aujourd'hui le département est en eux au
moins pour les territoires ruraux c'est
des régions qui ont un pouvoir
extrêmement important c'est un état
central qui revient sur les territoires
assez paradoxalement qui reprend la main
en tout cas sur les territoires et c'est
l'union européenne moi village de leur
1500 habitants je vais traiter des
dossiers à bruxelles aujourd'hui par
ailleurs sur l'intercommunalité et une
intercommunalité forte c'est à dire
qu'il ya beaucoup de compétences qui
s'occupe des ordures ménagères du
développement économique du
développement touristique actuellement
de l'équipement informatique des écoles
de la voirie c'est le cas chez moi là ma
communauté de communes 4000 habitants
elle est celle qui a le coefficient
d'intégration fiscale pardon le plus
importante des partenariats qu à noter
qu'elle plus où les communes ont le plus
donné de compétences bon j'ai jamais eu
comme maire au temps de travail c'est à
dire que c'est cesser aujourd'hui il
faut qu'on sorte de ces sujets très
techniques qui sont en compétences
obligatoires compétences facultatives
pour s'intéresser aux vrais problèmes
des gens et les vrais problèmes des gens
c'est pas des sujets de compétences
c'est un sujet qui est comment on
invente le 21e siècle dans un pays qui
est à l'afp qu'ils voient la fin d'une
civilisation la fin d'une histoire c'est
celle de l'exode rural c'est celle de
plein de choses ça marche aussi dans les
villes les problèmes des banlieues les
quartiers difficiles tout ça qu'est-ce
qu'on invente à la place et c'est notre
responsabilité à nous mais rey a
singulièrement maires ruraux d'inventer
ce nouveau modèle de vivre ensemble et
là il ya un travail considérable et un
boulevard pour tous les maires ruraux
effectivement comme le dit le collègue
on ne touchera pas aux communes rurales
ont lu ciel qui souhaite se rapprocher
elles ont la possibilité plus simplifiée
de le faire aujourd'hui pour la simple
et bonne raison qu on a trente six mille
bénévoles x 10 en moyenne probablement
dans ce pays et que c'est une richesse
incroyable qu'on ne va pas être des
fonctionnaires à la place des aînés
ruraux ou des difficultés du feu c'est
cette obsession de la taille en ce
moment depuis
deux ou trois ans ça a commencé à vous
pour les régions et ça vaut pour les
régions aussi et puis ça a commencé en
fait
il faut le rappeler sous la majorité
précédente c'est à la fois c'est ces
deux choses que je trouve dramatique
aller dans le sens extrêmement populiste
d'accompagner les mouvements sondagier
qui disent que les français n'ont plus
confiance dans leurs élus donc qu'est-ce
qu'on fait les uns et les autres sarko a
commencé là ça continue ben on va
diminuer le nombre d'élus on va essayer
de dire que effectivement il y en a trop
et on accompagne un mouvement qui va à
l'encontre du fondement de l'art et des
fondements de la république
de l'histoire de ce pays qui j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion de dire de la révolution
française a aujourd'hui est passée voilà
de la monarchie à la république tant
bien que mal au 19e à la république
décentralisée en 80 avec un président
qui a quand même marqué durablement
l'histoire de ce pays aujourd'hui on est
parti sur un phénomène inverse et on est
dans cette logique totalement populiste
en train de déstructurer le lien entre
les citoyens et ceux qui portent en leur
nom en leur nom une responsabilité une
responsabilité qui va loin qui est
pénale qui qui est celle du mieux être
sûr sur nos territoires et cette
obsession de la taille obliger les
communes à se mettre à 20000 habitants
ça n'avait rien à tortosa vous sans
aucun sens mais en même temps il est
vrai aussi il est vrai aussi qu'il y a
des intercommunalités qui sont des
coquilles vides des élus qui n'ont pas
voulu s'engager dans les politiques si
on fait le tour ne serait ce qu'en
côte-d'or de l'ensemble des
intercommunalités qu'on regarde la
réalité des compétences exercées pas
celle qu'elles ont je m'occupe de
développement économique qu'est ce que
vous faites en développement économique
rien
s'il ya aussi des coquilles vides et il
ya des lieux qui meurt et il est normal
que le gouvernement se disent il faut
qu'on cherche le moyen qu'il y ait de
meilleures réponses aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
sauf que pour l'instant ce qu'ils
proposent c'est
l'imposition d'un schéma mathématiques
pour tout dire administrative
technocratique et ça ça marche pas il
faut être sur l'incitation il faut être
sur la sanction éventuellement à 10
celui qui ne fait pas et bien on peut le
sanctionner financièrement cependant on
a plutôt ont plus intérêt à
sanctionner ceux qui font pas ou au
contraire accompagner ceux qui font donc
encore une fois l'objectif est et est
louable mais la méthode n'a pas de sens
pourquoi 20000 pourquoi pas 15 pourquoi
pas 10 pourquoi pas pourquoi pas cette
escale à lille hier soir hier soir on
sait âgées venant de masquer les vrais
dans la nièvre ne l'est pas forcément en
côte d'or n'est pas forcément dans les
rangs ne disons pas 15 2011 c'est
aujourd'hui qu'il ya deux dérogations
possibles sa famille le signe évident
donc très franchement c'est pas le sait
pas la discussion c'est pas le sujet on
discutait avec la collègue sont le
projet chez vous c'est d'aller sur le
périmètre du pays c'est une stratégie
qui est très bien dans d'autres
territoires chez moi c'est pas forcément
possible enfin très franchement c'est
pas le sujet le sujet c'est qu'est ce
qu'on fait est ce qu'on sait reconquérir
nos rues commerçantes est ce qu'on sait
faire du très haut débit partout et pour
tous voilà c'est ça de temps pour faire
tout ça à nerf de la guerre quand même
c'est quand même un point important
c'était aussi pour ça qu'on souhaitait
avoir patrick molinoz ce qui est vice
président de l'association des maires de
france qui est dans ce même qui
s'exprime là dessus en ce moment sur
effectivement la baisse des dotations
aux collectivités fanniemae pas content
on va le faire quand même
françois baroin le président de la mf
dit c'est très grave à cause de ça
l'économie française va mourir puisque
les coller des communes c'est plus que
grave ne paieront plus quoi que ce soit
est ce que vous êtes d'accord là dessus
est ce que il faut gagner alors le
paradoxe c'est que tout le monde est
d'accord pour faire des économies en
général jamais sur sa propre
collectivité jamais sur soi même donc en
gros le tout les messes que je suis
démagogues en disant tous les maires de
france sont d'accord pour qu'on fasse
des économies mais pas sur les communes
de france ça s'est passé pas juste parce
que non donne d'abord il y reprend là
par l'autorité le nomic
déjà effectivement c'est pas juste parce
que toutes les communes ne touche pas la
même chose non plus par habitant donc là
quand on parle de communes rurales le
fait de vouloir grossir absolument va
coûter beaucoup plus cher c'est à dire
que si on doit devenir puisque la
dotation da dépendent aussi des tailles
de communes de toute façon donc une
commune de 3500 habitants coûte plus
cher à l'état qu'une commune de 1500 ne
serait ce qu en dotation ensuite elle
coûtera plus aussi parce que si on
éloigne est ce que je voulais dire tout
à l'heure c'est qu'effectivement cette
cette politique du chiffre est assez
absurde puisqu'elle ne tient compte que
de la démographie et pas du tout de la
géographie la topographie alors elle en
tient maintenant un peu con mais quand
même dans les zones entières maintenant
un peu compte avec effectivement tous et
toutes ces dérogations que l'on peut
avoir et c'est cet heureux mais malgré
tout dans la pensée unique qui veut que
il faut qu'on supprime des élus et qu'il
faut qu'on supprime des communes on a un
petit peu cette réflexion or nos
communes sont pas comme en zone urbaine
où d'un côté de la rue c'est une commune
et de l'autre côté c'est une autre chez
nous il ya des kilomètres qui vous êtes
maire les économies c'est combien en
moins peu un globule de ça signifie quoi
dans vos communes de 500 habitants
prenons un exemple au moyen d'une petite
commune de 500 habitants c'est ses 30 à
40000 euros donc en moins
en 2011 alors
que
la dépense en divulguant notation que
l'on connaît elle est arrivée chez nous
hier ou avant-hier donc je sais pas
comment on fait pour dire ses trente ou
quarante mille heureusement commune chez
moi j'ai regardé avant de venir je n'ai
pas tout connaisseur de tout mais
dotation je perds sur quatre cent
cinquante mille euros à peu près de
dotations de l'état deux mille euros
c'est une paille ceux qui perdent en
effet si les communes de plus de 3500
habitants n'ont donc il faut aussi
beaucoup la nouvelle mais qui perce
singulièrement ses saveurs 100 millions
par ailleurs oui paradis encore mon
inter communalités probablement dans le
communiqué mais en fait tu es content
comme une somme et le pas de la dgr dont
il faut parler je vois là où on est
technique c'était ma dotation globale
dgf dotation globale nationale de l'état
derrière voilà c'est sur une commune de
500 habitants n'a mis en examen oui mais
ça monte au général noble ans et cela il
faut pas fumer les gens c'est faux pas
nous et le ragoût lors les les autres
les eaux mais c'est déjà moins 10 et
vous et les autres dotations mondo
globalement s'en sort c'est le premier
les deux joueurs dotation liste est
longue c'est ça que j'essaie des choses
et on a beaucoup simplifier les choses
par ailleurs personne ne parle de
supprimer les communes aujourd'hui c'est
pas ne fait pas dans le panneau
troisièmement ce qui est extrêmement
important et c'est là où il faut aussi
que les maires ruraux ofas touche
ensemble un effort de formation on est à
un moment on discute ont négocié le
contrat de projet entre l'état et la
région il ya des lignes de crédit pour
les territoires ruraux on est à un
moment où on bénéficie le programme
repère un programme leader plusieurs
millions d'euros on est à un moment on
renouvelle en bourgogne les contrats de
pays plusieurs millions d'euros on est à
un moment où la dotation de l'état qui
aide à l'investissement qui s'appelle la
detr ex dge est augmentée dans la nièvre
de 50% très franchement les moyens ils
sont là dont les a il faut aller les
chercher sur ces différents sur ses
différents programmes sur ces différents
projets et ne pas crier au loup parce
que on est sûr nous disposerons cassé il
concerne les communes plus importantes
mutations sestak on donne moins
automatiquement mais qu'il existe
d'autres crédits aller chercher si on
avait des choses le solde est négatif
et les enfers
d'argent j'appris colline aux
autochtones mon collègue delorme évoque
effectivement des fonds qui sont en
augmentation c'est vrai pour la detr
c'est vrai pour un certain nombre mais
qui sont essentiellement des fonds
d'aidé à l'investissement d'accord
essentiellement investissements des
communes qui a baissé et ça ce sont des
chiffres officiels de plus de 12 %
au niveau national
maintenant je pars de l'ensemble des
commandes et la difficulté
la difficulté pour une commune c'est de
dégager un peu de marge de manoeuvre
pour pouvoir faire le peu
d'investissement qu'on fait en rurale
parce qu'on n'est pas sur des sommes
phénoménales il faut qu'on soit
raisonnable on n'a pas énormément
sur les plus petites communes de gros
projets d'investissement en revanche
nous sommes animateurs créateur
gestionnaires de services publics qu'on
ne pourra plus gérer animé payer si on
continue sur cette pente là moi j'ai
appris c'est quoi ce que la cantine
scolaire cfc les campings et avisé sait
les cantines c'est la collecte des
déchets ménagers
c'est
simplement les activités ribéry scolaire
et extrascolaire jeu parvenir je note
que vous ne verrez pas tous de la même
manière dont j'ai hâte adhérents pas
tous la même chose mais la réalité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les baisses de dotations
de fonctionnement deviennent en
particulier pour les petites communes
comme une intermédiaire extrêmement
difficile à assumer je vais prendre tu
évoquais
les dotations qui arrive aujourd'hui il
ya un fonds qui a été créé c'est un peu
technique et qui s'appelle le fonds de
péréquation intercommunale le quick on
est en train de le faire noté
pauvres on prend aux riches honda
n'oppose sa ligne eu d'accord on prend
collectivités les plus riches et on
donne aux plus pauvres très bonne idée
on est tous d'accord là dessus si on a
un coût 1 100e de la justice et de
l'équité la collectivité que je préside
la communauté de communes du pays
d'alésia et de la seine depuis trois ans
en flic a été bénéficiaire trente mille
soixante mille 90000 euros 12 13 14 15
la le chiffre est tombé hier j'étais à +
90 l'année dernière je serai à - 5 cette
année il va falloir qu'on m'explique ce
il va falloir comme excessives c'est un
fond là je parle du parlement non
non non c'est pas bien
s'il vous plaît je parle de l'argent
pour le territoire ce territoire c'est
les communes et l'intercommunalité 30 60
90 bénéficiaires sur les trois dernières
années cette année - 5 c'est à dire que
globalement ce territoire composé de
communes ou intercommunalités père cent
mille euros c'est énorme et nominé l'a
donc la situation financière aujourd'hui
est le premier ministre l'a dit à
françois baroin avant-hier il entend la
difficulté des collectivités a dégagé
des marges d'investissement
il dit son inquiétude il comprend
l'inquiétude des collectivités face aux
pme aux entreprises du bâtiment et des
travaux publics si on continue si la
baisse se poursuit comme elle se
poursuit aujourd'hui nous serons
incapables d'investir l'avenir il faut
savoir que sur les 3 milliards 6
d'économies prévues
60% à pèse sur les communes de france
60% environ 30% sur les régions sur la
censure des départements alors même que
alors même que nous réalisons 60
question de l'investissement public et
donc les communes sont aujourd'hui les
maltraiter dray leur maman globalement
les maltraiter des économies alors les
chiffres son camp mais c'est une réalité
les choses sont quand même près par an
oui on a évoqué toutes les dotations il
ya une dotation qui s'appelle la
dotation de fonctionnement qui est la
plus importante et qui baissent très
fortement oui et il y à une compensation
partielle c'est vrai que la dotation des
justes en même temps
déficits publics oui mais
aujourd'hui tout le monde est convaincu
qu'ils marchent dans une petite commune
vous expliquer aux conseillers
municipaux qu'il faut faire quelques
économies tout le monde est convaincu
simplement c'est la proportion qui est
qui et quand même et non baisser les
dotations de fonctionnement ambiance et
c'est énorme et ça met en cause comme le
disait monsieur molino the le
fonctionnent très bien bazin n'ayant pas
fait très franchement il faut il faut
qu'on soit clair par rapport aux
téléspectateurs je comprends et je
partage que dit patrie je comprends ce
que vous dites mais on parle
effectivement des communes de france on
ne parle pas des communes rurales
aujourd'hui ces 17 ces dispositifs qui
sont effectivement que je combats aussi
avec lesquels je ne sais pas d'accord
touche prioritairement les
intercommunalités d'accord et les
communautés les communes qui sont plus
de 3500 habitants en gros donc sert
qu'il faut pas instrumentaliser les
maires les collègues de communes de
foncia
deux mois
quand même parce que c'est vrai que moi
j'ai entendu notamment le préfet de
l'yonne précisé que pour
l'investissement les aides de l'état
était toujours là sauf que ce qu'ils
oublient c'est que la detr c'est un
pourcentage est de la dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux à 7
vient en aide sur un projet
d'investissement c'est un pourcentage
qui est donné mais sur quelle base les
communes elles font leurs
investissements sur le reliquat de ce
qu'il leur reste du budget de
fonctionnement donc plus on baisse le
fonctionnement mois on a de quoi
investir et c'est pas parce qu'on peut
avoir une aide de 20 % que les 80%
restants dont soir à les pays donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas parce qu'on nous
baisse le fonctionnement
que enfin c'est parce que nourrit son
fonctionnement ne peut malgré tout pas
un risque encore les raisons de la
colère était pas forcément au début de
l'émission il nous reste deux minutes
avant la tranche de midi puis on aura un
quart d'heure après c'est aussi le
moment d'ouvrir un sujet mais qui
finalement dans la continuité de l'ue
nerf de la guerre et de l'argent sur
justement ces territoires ruraux
aujourd'hui fabien bazin commencer
l'émission en disant c'est aussi le
questionnement aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'on doit faire quel est l'avenir des
territoires ruraux vous parler d'exode
dans cette direction là
est-ce que ça c'est quelque chose une
question que se posent jean-françois
farenc les maires ruraux aussi c'est à
dire quand on est maire d'une petite
commune est-ce qu'on en est surtout
réduit à se préoccuper de lui de la
qualité de l'école enfin des murs de
l'école où quand il ya une école où est
ce que les maires se pose la question
tout à fait parce que bon dans nos
villages alors je confirme tout à fait
ce que disait monsieur bazin le
phénomène quand même nouveau c'est que
la diminution des populations dans l'est
dans les zones rurales s'est terminée
donc on a au mieux stabilisation et puis
parfois fin aux pires stabilisation et
parfois même une augmentation de la
population depuis une dizaine d'années
dans donc on voit arriver vous voit
arriver quand même on voit arriver des
jeunes agriculteurs qui remplace les
anciens y en a quand même un certain
nombre qui moi j'en ai deux dans ma
commune qui viennent d'arriver dans les
douze derniers mois on voit arriver des
entreprises de services on voit arriver
des artisans voit arriver des
télétravailleurs moi dans ma commune
j'ai deux personnes qui travaillent avec
une pour un éditeur une maison de
grosses maisons d'édition qui est
implantée aux états unis et donc kibaki
demande du haut débit départ des
facilités de travail donc effectivement
il faut accompagner ces gens alors
l'accompagnement n'est pas le même on
n'a pas beaucoup de marge de manoeuvre
pour accompagner un nouvel agriculteur
puisque ça relève de politiques qui sont
plutôt nationale obama mais t on à
l'accompagnement déjà pour m'aimer mais
bon ne serait-ce que l'accueil de
l'ecoute c'est très important et on
passe beaucoup de temps là-dessus parce
que ce sont des gens
aigris culture ici la vie de la commune
plus largement oui probablement et donc
il faut il faut créer il faut que nos
communes soit accueillante il faut qu'on
puisse aider aussi les les petites
entreprises qui arrivent dans le maquis
ddd zaki qui existent et qui continue
d'exister quand même est bon ça c'est
très important il ya un mouvement un
mouvement qui est enclenchée qui est un
mouvement important de retour vers l'est
vers l'est et vers des campagnes et les
études ne manque pas un jeu c'est
d'abord le concile bien sûr de rêve de
s'implanter avec il ya peut-être loin du
rêve à la réalité quand même je vous
coupe parce que c'est la fin de cette
première partie ça nous a donné envie de
continuer à débattre là dessus on se
retrouve juste après les informations de
midi